what's up everybody it's your host
Travis under here with 12 talks back
again this week we about to get into it
let's get right into
it early in the week I went to the
Nuggets home opener show Co prom some my
moves here goes the
[Music]
video I could have faded on him layup he
Tred to dunk on me he can't jump right
now we he can't dunk
though he definitely can't
dunk after the game of course you know
the goat came up LeBron James talk to
[Applause]
man yeah you know he came over show us
some love man we appreciate that
uh my first
time meeting him or seeing him play in
person that's my first NBA game too
overall so it's exciting nice to see and
nice to watch coach Prime used what he
saw for the Nugget to talk to us about
understanding our
role we started this season out on
belief we started this journey out on
belief and I want to know do you still
believe cuz I can recall
talking to you and looking at your eyes
seeing how you practice and seeing how
you wanted it the first time we walked
out there taching
you and I want to make certain the same
men are in this room the same coaching
staff is in this
room the same understanding the same
want the same desire the same feel the
same passion the same purpose the same
kill instinct is in this room do you
still believe the thing I was invited to
the basketball game the other night and
you talking about the Lakers versus the
world
champions and I don't just watch
basketball I know basketball with my
favorite sport just watch it watch it I
watch it because I love it I like the
the little things that's done the pics
rolls and and the post and the ball and
defense I love all that the details of
that stuff and I know that one
team everybody on that team bought in to
the role because they exhorted all
options what's your role do you
play are you so caught up and want to be
the guy that you can't even understand
your role you so caught up and want the
ball that you can't understand your
responsibility you so desire to be the
man that you don't understand you be
amongst men and still be
great what's your role and are you
willing to play it because time is of
the essence and I hate to say we running
out of it for the football part of it
but for life we not you got time but
what you going to do with your
life because the main thing that you put
all your marbles in is ticking
away and what you going to do with your
T yeah man every got to
understand you got to roll we on the
field just like the old line got to
understand the whole team got to
understand everybody got a role key role
in what we're doing even scout team
players they got to go out and dominate
and help us out for us to get ready for
the next game for the following game uh
we just gotta be focused pretty much
what he's telling us we got to start
beli just cuz we got a couple losses
don't mean anything we got to go ahead
then compete and win so on once the game
started I was locked in on defense you
know first interception I've been
watching that play it just I've been
watching a lot of film on defense this
week so my first interception was just
easy it was what I studied I told my
coach coach AB right there that I told
him like coach I'm gonna pick that one
off I've been telling them all week
coach I promise you I'm gonna pick it
off him and Coach Mattis and then game
time came I picked it off that's why I
ran up to him cuz cuz matth is in the
booth so I can't run up to him so I ran
up to him and let him know I told you
come pick
it simple and easy and then my second
interception they try me again and this
is this a play that I really study I
studied this play like
from day one cuz I knew he was going to
throw that pass they threw that pass
like 90% of the time and if they did it
they was trying to get that pass every
time so I knew exactly what the
quarterback was thinking what he was
looking at so I made it seem like I was
playing on my dude but I wasn't jump
caught another interception and that's
what come with film study watching film
study that's how you get the ball in
your hands on defense how be a ball hog
understanding what the opponent is doing
so that's what I did I studied my
opponent last week and I'm G study him
this week and had the same
results hopefully just go out there keep
working
just stay T to myself continue to
work this week I made history on snaps
on both
sides talking about it being tough
hey man this it's not tough to me man it
just what I love to do at the end of the
day football is
football go there play no matter how
many snaps I take I'm still ready to go
play and that's
it shador was definitely under a lot of
pressure to this game but it's a reason
he got a l in this
jersey it's really
frustrating but again we got to go out
there we we just got to have more
practice we got to practice practice how
we gonna play we just run on the same
page basically so just got to watch film
get
better that's it gota get better D gotta
get better defense can approve you know
we have four turnovers offense can
definitely
approve we didn't play the game wanted
to play on offense and we still let up
too many points on defense so we still
got a lot to work on and that's it
coach PR didn't hold back on the biger
picture after the game definitely
didn't trying to keep Shure upright
healthy the big picture you go get new
L that's the picture I'mma paint it
perfectly yeah Ain nothing El say about
it just gota get better AMA gota step up
this game we count on them we need them
everybody tried to play their role last
week but online we got to we got to work
we got to work but I believe in them I
believe they going to do what we need
them to do this weekend so just got to
stay behind them keep believing them
don't get down on them make sure they
know you're there so that's the type of
Team you need at the game was over yeah
you know y'all seen on YouTube a couple
of dude stuff got
stolen it's kind of ignorant
by I don't know why people
still they're going to get in touch in
the lock during the game during the game
they stole the
chain insane
bro so yours during the game go play
football bro know your save dog
messed up bro dur in the game boys get
back in the lock room
crazy and
money that's the crazy part I mean
that's why I'm wear jurry bro I try to
say that I can't wear jewelry I'm not
flashy on you think I got anything that
you would like but I still messed up to
the team bro to my teammates because
like they hard workk money on that stuff
one of the camera guys got their money
stolen so that's kind of messed up bro
people they work for this stuff and
before they get stolen out a football
game after we thinking our stuff is safe
like I I'm not bringing no bags no more
to away games
like you won't see no away you won't see
me with no bags way again I probably
have a book bag and that's it like all
that extra stuff no sir I don't mess
with getting my stuff stolen cuz I would
have still been in Cali right now trying
to get my stuff back yeah not
crazy now it's time for overreaction and
not
overreaction you know what we gotta do
so let's get right into it what up chat
y'all finally loaded
in look at man you think it's a game
don't
you I even do look
but this is so funny I have problems
with Shiloh coming to class on time to
eighth period Spanish I also have other
behavioral and participation concerns it
is I don't even want to say what else
it's ignorant then Mr Lewis right charow
continues to disrupt my class it's never
on task and at times passing gas while
lecture is going on you fing in class
man D I I I had to do what I had to do
he didn't how you going just fart in
class he let me go to the
bathroom how are you just going to sit
up there and fart and try to be the the
baby all attention is not good attention
man I wasn't even trying to get I wasn't
trying to you're trying to be the class
clown no I was yes you are not reaction
class is a class not reaction farting in
class I would need to have a sit down
that was only one
time
Sho is funny
bro that is something sh would do bro he
is a Class Clown but it's not
overreaction bro it's definitely not
over reaction next up we got
next yeah Manor was definitely shooting
bricks see I can make that shot though
you know I a I got a sweatsuit on I
ain't play basketball in a minute know
been sitting in football for a minute
I'm definitely like that though the
basketball court so definitely a
reaction I'm definitely I ain't got to
stick the football I got basketball in
my back everybody know that that watch
my YouTube videos actually so yeah B
report if y'all want to come watch me
play basketball in the
offseason you're
welcome CA I Get
Buckets all right next what we go
next I could really hop on the court and
drop like you know no little TV pass
is that Patrick Mahomes
2.0 no that's a good pass
though oh my God he did zip that but
that's not a over I mean not
overreaction that's a good pass you
can't defend a no look pass never mind
that's overreaction because yes you
can't defend it if the man was on him he
would have been able to pick
it so
definitely could defend it but that's a
great great pass Dylan Brooks is
capping yeah he definitely was capping
because uh he definitely want to go and
drop buckets on
them yeah over reaction what we got next
May cofy is nasty yes bro don't even
quarterback at the University of
Kentucky and I have been known to put
mayonnaise in my coffee sometimes
overreaction x x now I don't want to see
this come on bro
want to see
that
huh bro
what's I mean they did get the upset
probably because he did that to his
chest
nah he is dedicated this is real team
Pride not a overreaction he's
dedicated all right we got another
Monday Night Football game
y'all are one in one and know we get who
yall think is winning this
week y one in one chat do y'all think is
winning are we gonna start a pool or
no Ryan are we gonna start a pool or
no all right yeah let's see Raiders
Lions what we
got Lions all the
way okay okay okay
okay chat one and one record
[Music]
5050 5050 54
45 Lon taking off
6040 all right so I guess the Lance
going wi it's been on line for a little
minute the chat is finally coming back a
live how's me and LeBron it was
good definitely a great
experience
all right it's been a crazy week of
football we got basketball and baseball
all going let's look at the best plays
and see if we could do that let's get
right into it new
game new
week could I do that yes I could do that
anything with basketball wait never
mind no I can't do
that now it's the backboard now back see
if it was all man I could do that bro
I'm L 2.0
bro I could do
that I can do this I can dunk on two
people at one time nobody want to jump
me
bro I could do that for
sure I could do
that for
sure yes I can do that I can catch
that
I can catch
that I can do that for
sure all right next up we got a
blur let's look at some Bean top from
this past week you know how we get let's
get right into it oh yall seen this
blur he got that foot in hand know that
back
HT yeah that's definitely a blur on this
said got a foot in great catch great
Focus we got next you are you at
Texas oh I seen this catch he M two
people yeah I seen this
BL and I was a P key oh hockey actually
th the
flag yes I seen that bro that jump was
crazy that's a freaking head top out of
this
world give me
that
BL for a
touchdown great
catch it's a great catch
[Music]
boy hey I ain't gonna lie we got some
good blurs this week we had two great
blurs what a good blur good blur all
right yall know what time it is remember
the game from last week we play the
video stop it halfway see what happened
next we got to guess got to get it right
so let's get into
it first clip what we
got
uh fig go double dinks and goes in chat
help me out help me out hurry up hurry
up hurry up the blocki go SC or state
tries to fake fails come on y not
helping all right double dingon goes in
sound kind of crazy
crazy what was the
score
uh
uh n they definitely not in the right
spot to block
it doesn't look like a fake
hey I'm right I know I
am bro it's a fake
bro chat y'all let me
down why y let me down chat all right
next St stuff is C us not BR bro
D told
you know it was a drop he was too
open I already know it was a
drop
next oh that was no that wasn't last
one I know what
[Music]
happened makes the
catch n makes the
catch
I got a 50 grade sh
crazy he called the
ball and he can't touch the ball cuz
somebody else touched it first even
though he went out of
bounds
yeah
let's go all right y'all before we get
out of
here y know upcoming
game I had a good game last week not
offense but on defense I had to come up
and show up show out on
defense uh this game this week we have
no other choice but to win we can't
continue to lose we got to go out and
dominate be focused locky in this week
we got a lot of stuff to do a lot of
stuff to improve on gotta start back
believeing get this DB fix the on line
fix the D line fix the defense the
offense everybody got to be perfect this
game we got to have a perfect game we
have yet to put two parts together we
either put the defense together and not
the offense or the offense together and
not the defense so that's what we got to
do we got to come together as a team as
a
unit and put both sides together offense
and defense espe teams together special
teams played great last week too so yeah
we got to put everything together get
ready for this week dominate is home
gotta protect the home field homecoming
for a lot of players
so gota finish dominating go in dominate
challenge this week is the win by any
means and it's your host Travis
Hunter and we out see you next time see
you next Monday and the Raiders I mean
the Lions better win chat cuz y'all one
and one so get right see y'all next
time